Gary you mentioned something about
motorcycles the other day what was your
issue yeah
um
why motorcycles can stand up uh they're
they're Transformers that's why
next question
So when you say stand up not after you
put up the kickstand you mean you can
just roll on its own yeah without
anybody on it you know
stand on the seat while the thing is
rolling for example I've seen that yeah
the display bike teams they're fantastic
yeah yeah so I for the longest while and
I count myself among those who would
give the answer that you have spinning
wheels that are basically gyroscopes
and that they gyroscopically stabilize
the motorcycle by the way this same
would apply to Bicycles of course right
yes because
in fact there was a famous scene in
famous because of people talked about it
I thought it was
clear and present but I didn't realize
how many people didn't know that if you
set a bicycle moving down a hill there's
nobody on it you'll just keep rolling
and keep going until you hit something
until it hits something for a long time
longer than you would expect and that
was revealed in the movie Butch Cassidy
and the Sundance Kid yeah and one of the
in one of the Romantic scenes with
Robert Redford and Catherine Ross I
think it was
um it's also revealed in my driveway as
a kid and I got into a hell of a lot of
trouble because boy do you know how much
that bike cost I cannot believe that you
were throwing that bike down
that's what you see you run and you just
let the bike go and then yeah then it
becomes a ghost bike yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah so so that was a common
explanation and I've even given that
explanation but I recently read that
someone did an experiment where they
added wheels that spin the opposite way
of the wheels they're not connected to
the ground or anything but they spin in
the opposite direction which cancels out
the physical angular momentum of the of
the rotating wheel so the whole system
no longer has a net gyroscopic Force
operating on it
and it's still stayed up so it's like
it's it's rolling down the hill but then
let's say you have like a a balancing
pole with two wheels on it and then
they're spinning in the opposite
direction
like correct and then figure out a way
to do this so that then then there's
there's no net gyroscopic stabilizing
Force because it's been canceled out
just through the laws of physics so but
so it's still maintained its course and
so so
here's what's going on it's fascinating
it's it's more complicated with a
bicycle than in other examples I could
give but
a system is stable in whatever it's
doing
if
it's Center of mass is as low as it
could be
okay within a range of which is the
whole deal with Motorsport where they're
always trying to get the sense of mess
as low as possible yes and electric cars
put their batteries on the not on them
yes but as low as possible on the bottom
so that you have to look because watch
what happened
if the center mass is so low
that anything you do to that object
raises the center of mass
it doesn't want to do it
it always wants to bring the center mass
as close to the Center of the Earth as
possible that's why you guys remember
Weebles yeah
there they go so you push them and then
it writes itself back up well what's
happening because in its righted
position the center of mass is as low as
it possibly can be and if you do
anything else with a Weeble you are
raising the center of mass and that's
not what the Weeble wants to do relative
to Earth so once you've raised the
center of mass it says I'm going back to
where I was and the center Mass drops
down it gets closer to the Center of the
Earth in that case only by a few inches
but it'll do it so it turns out
the design of a bicycle where the center
and mass or the front section and the
back and the chair
is that if you set the thing rolling
down the hill and it begins to lean
what will happen is the front wheel will
turn right into that lean
correct okay and write itself okay so
the bike won't necessarily go in a
straight line but if it curves
its tendency will be to write itself
so neat I could yeah I'm on I'm on a
higher wire on my bike because I'm a bit
like that okay oh wait wait it's almost
big okay now you want to run what's
happening why why why why why you want
to write a rifle on a highway let's just
do the high wire first and then we can
stick it on a bike if you want okay so
the high wire the reason why they carry
this big stick that's left and right
okay it's not to balance them
no this is not what it's doing really no
okay now you've got me okay
that balance Pole
is floppy have you noticed that yes it's
not a rigid pole I so thought you were
going to drop a gag man yeah okay
I was gonna say it happens to a lot of
high wire Walkers it's okay but I'm not
going to do that okay cool leave it
alone oh exactly it's not a rigid pole
because you could say you can use that
to balance no because they're not using
it to balance they get a floppy pole so
that the side on the left flops downward
and the side on the right flops downward
okay and the system the high wire Walker
plus the pole
has a center of mass now that is so low
that if he starts tipping to the left
the center mass is raised because the
pole is out there uh
counterbalancing him okay so yes I'll
use the word balance in that context but
it's all about the center of mass if he
tips the center Mass raises and it wants
to lower the center of mass once again
so he can easily I mean if you still
have the talent to do this stay on the
pole on the wire because the pull plus
the wire him on the wire is the lowest
Center of mass of the system that you
can get and any if you don't see him
walking with this up over his head do
you you don't see that
okay it's always holding it down low
it's always held pretty low right down
by the waist yeah right by the waistline
so Gary now you want to have the high
wire act on a motorcycle okay my boy so
let's not go too bad okay so there's
probably some kind of GrooVe in the tire
for it to stay on the wire
off and use the rim oh that would work
oh for sure because the rim is concave
yeah right so that that's an interesting
way to make that work but
um if you are up above the wire
relative to the tires you'd want the the
floppy uh
stick you'd want that to go even wider
out to the sides and even be even more
droopy and that would give you
tremendous stability
in doing this exercise
so Gary I don't know did I go where I
had to go in that answer for you I think
you did yeah I mean just thinking about
would it work then for electric
motorbikes because there's no engine and
generally the engine is the lower part
of the whole thing oh so
that then
and would that then work in the same way
because I've seen motorbikes where the
the batteries go up one of the yeah the
difference is that the the the the the
weight of an engine on a bike is pretty
evenly distributed so that it makes the
bike balanced to ride so once you just I
mean it's between the rear wheel and
where your feet go and wait he's not up
in the not in the front wheel right
right nonsense so that's normally the
way they position engines but for
battery you can see it like they sit
like right under the front fork
sometimes and then sometimes at the
bottom of the bike so it's interesting I
don't but I'd have to conclude Gary that
yes if they're putting batteries up the
down the down tube and up the tubes then
that's changing where the center mass of
the of the system is and it can only be
less stable for that reason yes yeah
perfectly what we need is delivery
Riders on less stable bikes doing 30 odd
miles an hour down down the street the
wrong way with our food perfect because
in the city Uber Eats are people on on
motor on motorized bicycles it's not
people in cars so that's all I can tell
you on that Gary were you were you are
you good to go on that thank you yeah so
just remember I was fascinated by The
Balancing poll because that is something
I'm thinking well that's for balance but
it's not it's a different thing all
together it's a different I mean yes
there's something for what you said the
center of mass it's for Center of mass
it's it's to keep the center mass as low
as possible and in some cases the center
of mass is in fact I think it's in every
case the center mass is below the wire
so that as you tip the center Mass says
I want to get as low I want again I want
to get as close to the center of Earth
as possible and that's directly below
the wire
and you're on top of the wire so
everybody's stable
there it is
interesting
so it's not as dangerous as they make
out then
I think most things are not if you boost
the odds in your favor by training by
practice by physics
than anyone else looking at what you do
is imagining themselves in that
situation and how dangerous it would be
for them
they're not imagining you in that
situation in that situation imagining
how non-dangerous it otherwise is for
those who are trained Chuck Gary that's
all timers for this exercise yeah and
StarTalk sports edition we got
explainers there too yeah we had
curiosity as well Neil yeah the rest of
the universe is not the only place where
you scratch your head and say really is
that how that works why uh Sports is
Right riding a motorcycle and a wire
oh really
the Neil deGrasse Tyson here you're a
personal astrophysical as always keep
looking up
foreign
[Music]